que dit la lettre de menaces de mort
reçue par le maire de poison son auteur
laisser-aller l'ue jusqu'au 30 novembre
pour renvoyer ces soi disant amis
parasites hors de la ville à défaut le
maire dit la lettre sera éliminée pour
haute trahison ainsi que ces vermines
terroristes un amalgame et des menaces
que le maire dénonce
moi je veux bien assumer toutes mes
responsabilités mais j'estime que si on
a quelque chose à me dire on vient me le
dire en face
chouette connaître le coupable
reconnaître la tête de coupable j'aime
bien savoir
bon pas d'idées pas piste non ça peut
être un voisin quand même un village à
côté on se bat depuis deux semaines le
centre de vacances des enfants du métro
située à pois the accueille une
vingtaine de migrants venus de calais
c'est la préfecture qui a organisé leur
arrivée sans que cela ne pose de
problème particulier
là il ya tout ce qu'il faut c'est vrai
que c'est spacieux et c'est bien et ça
se passe bien justement très très bien
c'est des gens y sont pas désagréable du
tout on les voit on les côtoie à part
leur langue qu'on peut pas trop discuté
avec eux mais dans l'ensemble c'est
déjanté aux yeux de la loi les menaces
de mort adressées au maire de poison ne
sont bien sûr pas anodine son ou ses
auteurs risquent jusqu'à trois ans
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amendé
la missive menaçant l'élu ne restera pas
lettre morte
le maire a déposé plainte et une enquête
est en cours